[Music]
hello
ladies and gentlemen i said ladies and
gentlemen again why do i keep doing that
i don't know
you got bad habits
[Laughter]
is the audio good people because we're
having audio problems with this [ __ ]
laptop we don't know what it is ghosts
yeah which is the movie that we're
working on this week yeah so
doing this movie here it was called
better watch out yeah we're doing
holiday movies all this week because you
know run up to christmas so that's how
it do
yeah this one was uh this one was all
right i like this one actually
this is this is all right um this was
all right
yeah it's all right it didn't really
pull me into it i really wasn't quite in
the mood for it
but if i had been in the mood for it i
probably would enjoy it a lot
better there's it's not a bad movie now
this one i
had actually this is actually my this
was my second time seeing it because i
saw it last
year last year or the year before now
this came out
i guess it premiered at fantastic fest
back in 2016
but it didn't really get a wide release
well what counts as a wide release for
an indie movie
until 2017. so that's why i put 2017 on
the thing
um it's on shutter it might be on 2b2
but i'm not entirely sure like but i
watched it on shutter because
in their holiday horrors section
now the thing about this movie though is
that
it has a twist and it's really really
hard to talk about the movie without
talking about what the twist is
yeah so should we spoil it or not no i
don't spoil it
i don't think enough people have seen
the movie maybe not
sophie's saying hi from work mango's in
there
so so if you gotta come down visit us
again
help jenny get some work done
the uh yeah this one here
it's kind of like it starts off as kind
of like the standard thing where
babysitter has to come into the house to
watch the kid
you know it's a [ __ ] horror movie you
kind of set up
then you see the kid and the kid isn't
very the kid isn't [ __ ] young at all
the kids like the same age as the
babysitter
well no because well okay now in in the
movies universe yeah the kid yeah
whose name is luke in the movie he's
actually played by an actor named uh
levi something when i saw the kid i was
like man that kid's [ __ ] all
that kid is the same age as the
babysitter no in the movie he's supposed
to be 12 and the actor when he made it
was 13.
okay so um and the girl is supposed to
be 17. i think she was a little bit
older
like when she shot it they looked about
the same age once again they weren't
though once you get to my age
for snappers you all look like babies
they all look like babies
no he i thought i thought he was about
16
and i thought she was about 16 or 17. no
that's what i thought
that actor was only 13. when he shot
that and he was actually supposed to be
12. because they're the same size
yeah but you know she was just like low
but yeah so that was so the whole setup
of this
um also can i say that i love how like
um the [ __ ] parents in this were
played by patrick warburton and virginia
madsen
they're not in it that much but i
thought it was like really cool that
they
like had them kind of cameo in there i
think it only took them like five days
to shoot their scenes or whatever
so the setup of this is that
ashley is a 17 year old girl she lives
in the neighborhood and she
has babysat for this kid like pretty
much his whole life since he was you
know
until and you know since she was old
enough to babysit
and this 12 year old boy has
romantic feelings for this 17 year old
girl but of course she just sees him as
a kid because he has a kid she has
boyfriend
you know she's going off to college next
year
and she's you know she's moving
somewhere else and all this other stuff
she's not really worried about it
however unbeknownst to her on this night
this christmas evening when she's going
over here to babysit this little kid
he has decided that tonight's the night
he's gonna make his move
yeah that's some weird so he's like
trying to like
impress her by basically like doing a
[ __ ] that a 12 year old would do to
impress a 17 year old girl like
look i can drink a whole bottle of
champagne or like look at it and he's
like trying to get you know touch her
thigh
like trying to like make out with her
and [ __ ] and she's just like whoa bro
what the [ __ ] are you doing and then
he's it's it's good because
the kid that's in this is great um
because and like i said it's really
really hard to talk about without
spoiling it because
he comes across as like an awkward kid
but also one that's really precocious
and is like really smart and so you can
tell that he's really frustrated
that he's still being treated like a
child even though he doesn't see himself
as a child
so i think he's like really really good
at conveying that
and then like the [ __ ] that he has to
convey later on
okay here's one thing i will say which
is maybe kind of a spoiler did you guys
see the movie the babysitter
um which we we did um we talked about
the
sequel babysitter killer queen i don't
remember if we ever
um reviewed the original or not although
i really really liked the original um
very much but this it's kind of similar
to that this movie kind of reminded me
of the babysitter in a lot of ways
so that's not necessarily a spoiler but
i'm just gonna say that there is kind of
like a twist thing in there but yeah
what happens is
um he's trying to make out with her and
then
it seems that like all this kind of
ambiguous creepy [ __ ] like starts
happening just like in your standard
like babysitter horror movie
where she keeps getting phone calls and
no and no one's there
um the pizza guy shows up even though
they didn't order a pizza and it has
mushrooms on it even though the kid
hates mushrooms
it's like so all this you know and then
like some of the christmas decorations
like turn up in random places and she's
like kind of wigging out and then it
seems like somebody like breaks in the
house and it kind of like goes on from
there
um so i will say like i said it's very
very hard
to not spoil this because because i
think i really really like the twist in
it i really really like the way that
this went
and i really like that it almost kind of
starts out
as i don't want to say light-hearted
necessarily because it does have like a
horror intruder type of thing but it's
also kind of funny
and you know it's kind of christmassy
and kind of a black comedy kind of thing
and then like right at about the halfway
point it goes like
more full-on into horror and it's like
not really funny anymore
you know what i mean so it's kind of
like has that kind of like hard shift
but i think it's like really really well
done
the crazy thing about this and this is
something that i did not
know until i was researching this movie
i
found this there's this channel called
good bad flicks and he does like really
like breakdowns of like all the behind
the scenes kind of [ __ ] and he did one
on this movie
so i got a lot of info from that
originally this movie
which was written and directed by a guy
called uh chris peck over
um he was originally gonna shoot this
in north carolina i think for half a
million but then i guess he met this
australian producer and the australian
producer was basically like hey
um i'll give you three million dollars
if you shoot it like on the fox studios
lot i think like in sydney australia
so he was like oh three million dollars
okay so they actually shot this in
australia
and most of the actors as far as i could
determine are australian but you would
never
guess that yeah like from listening to
them i don't think they were
i didn't know they're australian but i'm
pretty sure that that most of
the three main actors i think are
australian those please correct me if
i'm wrong
also another thing too is that the house
where this was shot because this is
basically
a one location film it's all in one
house and the yard and everything
the house and the yard and everything is
all
a set they essentially built a house
and they built like 60 feet of yard like
all around it
and they and yeah you would never never
know like the only part that was shot
like on
location there's like a little bit of a
preamble at the beginning where they're
kind of like going down the
street and they shot that in like
minnesota or something like that because
it's like all wintery
but they shot this in australia in
uh when was it january or something like
that which is summer in australia
so they're like when we're shooting this
there's fake snow and [ __ ] like that
everywhere but it was
hot it was like 85 degrees like when
they were shooting it so they had like
pursuit they
said it was like really jarring because
you'd walk onto this set that looks like
a house in a yard
that has [ __ ] snow and christmas
decorations and you know christmas [ __ ]
all over it
and then it's like and then it was like
summer and it was sweltering
so it was super weird but i didn't
realize as i saw some behind the scenes
shots of this they essentially built
this entire house
and they're just like they built it as
an open floor plan so that you know the
camera
crew could like move around in there and
they could get like all these
interesting shots and [ __ ]
but i was just kind of like holy crap
man but it's just like this
i mean as far as holiday horror movies
go
this is a good one i like that i like
that it you think it's going one way but
then it's slightly you know
it kind of goes off kilter like it
catches you on off guard a little bit
i like that it has a sort of meta
home alone type thing because they do
make a lot of like home alone homages
in this and the guy that directed it
even said he kind of wanted it to make
it seem like it was in
not necessarily the same universe as
home alone but he's like
i was imagining that this was like the
house next door like to the mcallister
house like from home alone
he's like so i was kind of magic because
there is a really really good
home alone gag in this which is pretty
gruesome which is kind of like the
signal for the movie going more often
horror direction
also the guy that plays um
ashley's ex-boyfriend who shows up at
some point i think his character name is
jeremy in the movie
he was that he was in the car and i'm
looking at him going god damn it it's
like that dude is so familiar who the
[ __ ] is that
and when i was looking him up he was
like well he was in the power rangers
movie and i'm like i didn't see that
[ __ ] it's not his power rangers movie
he was billy from stranger things
the mullet guy like the hot guy with
like the [ __ ] camaro whatever the
[ __ ] he had that everybody was like in
love with it was like banging all the
moms and stuff
he was that guy so that guy he only has
like a really really small part he's
only at it for maybe like five minutes
or something
but it was just it was bugging me and i
can't believe that i didn't remember it
was like stranger things guy
but that was like who was it but so yeah
so this i guess this came out before
i can't remember when the first season
of stranger things came out but this
might have been like before
that so this was kind of like his big
break i suppose
but yeah this is uh like i said if
you're looking for a good
christmas horror movie you could
certainly do worse than this one like
if you like the babysitter you will
probably like this one because it's kind
of similarly
themed and uh kind of has a similar vibe
to it
and uh yeah i just i just appreciate it
a lot i liked it a lot you you liked it
yeah you liked it yeah
[Laughter]
but i think my favorite thing about it
is probably that kid that was in it i
mean that kid was [ __ ] great he was a
really good actor and especially when i
found out that he was
almost the same age as his character so
he was still essentially a kid he was
only 13 years old
and the fact that he [ __ ] pulled off
the crazy [ __ ] that he had to do in this
movie was just like that was pretty
[ __ ] good
but you know what i mean and the the kid
that plays uh his friend was okay too i
think um
was really good too i think he was 14.
but yeah so everybody's kind of like
age-appropriate in this so you uh victor
says is this an old movie or a newbie
it's 2016 2017.
um it was i think it premiered at a
festival in 2016 but it didn't get
released it seems new
until 2017. yeah you wouldn't really
know it's very very recent
um so and oh i wanted to say too that i
think originally when it was originally
made or it was originally uh shopped
around
when i when it premiered at fantastic
fest i think it was called safe
neighborhood
but when it was like when the producer
picked it up and wanted to distribute i
think it's distributed by well go usa
which is the same company that uh
distributed train to busan
yeah in the us they were like can we
change the title because it's
we want to make it more christmasy and
that doesn't really seem like a
christmassy
title so they like did the whole
marketing thing with better watch out
and stuff like that
we'll say too that um i don't know if if
the guy would ever be interested in
making a sequel but you totally could
i mean i think like the end of it it was
it's one of those good
endings that it was like a satisfying
ending
and you could leave it like that and
everyone would be fine with it but
if you wanted to make a sequel you could
absolutely do that
you know what i'm saying so it's it's
not open-ended but
you know you could move on from it if
you really really wanted to but you know
um so yeah like i said it's on shutter
it
might be on 2b2 i'm not really sure i
think some people also have also seen it
uh said that it was on amazon prime so
you might want to check on there too
uh if it's there but yeah so if you're
looking for some holiday horror movies
then
check this one out because i really
liked it a lot and um we're gonna do
another one tomorrow i already got it
planned out
it's another one that i've already seen
that i saw last year the year before
but i really like that one as well and
so i wanted to kind of save that until
last because
because i really like it but yeah so tom
looks like he's
yeah i'm kind of bored
yeah yeah yeah yeah
man what's the matter i just want to go
for a walk oh
i'm gonna go for a walk and then i want
to take a nap probably it's about time
for an old man
yeah it's about his nap time i don't
know man he needs to get put down he's
getting fussy
[Laughter]
i wouldn't can i please make a shirt
with your face on it that says i'm
getting fuzzy
i'm thinking about what i'm going to
cook i got that chicken thought and
they're going to make something
make something i know what i'm going to
do what are you going to do i'm going to
make that
sog paneer oh okay and then i'm going to
make some chicken on the side
so you can either have it with chicken
or with that's right because we just
bought that big block of paneer because
last time we were at the indian market i
was like let's get a big block of paneer
because we haven't had any of it sounds
good
it does so i want to i want to make that
before that spinach goes bad
yeah because we didn't we got two boxes
of spinach back there yeah we'd better
do something with that because you don't
want that to go
waste about damn movie i'm thinking
about how i'm going to cook that spinach
yesterday well yesterday he made like a
really nice like thai chicken curry yeah
with like some potatoes and some
eggplant and stuff in it yeah i had a
little bowl of that for lunch that was
fresh basil leaves in there oh yeah
that's oh i thought that was the curry
leaves that we had
as i picked down the backyard oh well
[ __ ] oh yeah right out of nature [ __ ]
that sounds like what happens yeah we
have a little basil plants
yeah all right so uh yeah check this
movie out and we'll be back tomorrow
for another matinee our last little
christmas matinee
of the year and uh thanks everybody for
stopping by and we'll see you again
tomorrow
bye